>> All right. Hi
everyone, good afternoon.
So, my name is
Phebe Vayanos and I'm
Assistant Professor of
Industrial Engineering and
Computer Science at USC
and also Associate Director of
the Center for AI
in Society at USC.
On behalf of my team,
I would like to present
the problem that we have
identified in the context
of AI and public health.
It's the problem of
using AI to prevent VL.
So, as Rishabh
presented yesterday,
VL is a huge public
health problem.
In fact, it's the second
largest parasitic killer
in the entire world
after malaria.
Every year there's about 200,000
infections and
70% of those cases,
actually of the cases
that occur in India,
occur in Bihar and UP.
There is a treatment that's
available for treating VL,
but unfortunately it's
not widely available,
it's not easily accessible.
The way that VL spreads
is actually by means of
these sandflies which can
carry the disease
and can infect you.
There is a way of preventing VL,
which is by these indoor
residual spray approach.
This basically is a spray
that we go and place indoors
inside houses and can
effectively eradicate the flies,
and so prevent the spread
of the disease.
The way this is performed
is basically twice yearly,
before and after
the monsoon season.
Unfortunately though, what
happens is that we need to
have health workers that
actually go and do the spraying.
A number of health workers
that we have at our disposal,
amount of spray that we have at
our disposal are both limited.
Also the spring needs
to occur during
a particular time
window in the year
and so we have also
a time constraint.
AI can actually help
address this problem.
In particular, the way in which
we can view this problem,
what we need to do is we
have a finite number of
health workers that can start at
a particular village in India,
and for each health worker,
we can decide which cities
they will visit and the
sequence in which they
will visit these villages.
So this is a vehicle
routing problem.
Whenever a public health worker
visits a particular village,
they can conduct
the spraying and we can
decide the intensity
of the spraying.
Depending on the intensity,
we will eradicate a certain
proportion of the flies which in
turn will prevent
a certain portion
of the disease from spreading.
We have some data
already available at
our disposal to help
inform these decision
making problem.
These are basically
patient-level data.
So we have for both Bihar and UP
historical cases,
so we can figure out when
and where a particular
individual was affected by VL.
I understand that
these people are also
tracked in the system
so we can know whether
they were cured.
For each that we get,
we also have
information about areas
that were actually
sprayed in the past.
We have a patient-level data,
demographic
information and so on,
and we also have elements
that can help that actually
impact the efficacy
of the spraying
such as cleanliness
of the households,
the status of
the village et cetera.
Apparently, if, say
your house is not so clean,
then the efficacy of
the spraying will drop.
We believe that there
are some additional data
that we could collect that could
help inform our decision
making even better.
In particular, deaths due to VL.
So these would be cases
that have not been
reported at the time
when they occur
but that resulted in death.
Also, additional data that
can help us understand maybe
what other factors could
affect the efficacy
of the spraying,
like weather conditions
and things like that.
What we propose to do is to take
this historical data that
we have at our disposal,
like historical cases of VL,
whether the treatment
was successful,
weather data et cetera,
to train certain machine
learning models that will
help us understand where will
VL strike in the current year.
That will help us also
understand the effectiveness and
the efficacy of a particular
spraying strategy.
We will use that information
then to inform,
to feed into an optimization
model that would actually
generate these routes for
each and every of health worker.
We believe that this approach
is very promising.
In particular, we believe that by
using these data-driven
optimization approach,
we'll be able to improve
both the efficacy and
effectiveness of
these VL prevention strategy.
We envisage
some possible non-technical
roadblocks that we may face.
In particular,
our proposed approach,
because it will be implemented
actually by the government,
it does require
government buy-in,
but fortunately Rishabh does have
contact with policymakers
in the area,
so we're crossing our fingers.
Some additional challenges relate
to dropout rates of
these health workers.
It seemed that every year
some of them dropped out,
in which case you may need to
unexpected have to retrain
health workers to teach
them how they can
do the spraying.
There are some ethical
concerns in particular.
So we have these basically
scarce resources
that we're seeking to
decide how to allocate.
If we allocate them some place
and not somewhere else,
we're effectively deciding who
to treat and who
not to treat like
who may get the disease
and who won't.
This is very serious in my view.
Ethical concern and how can
we somehow tackle it
is maybe not clear.
We have, of course,
privacy concerns
related to the fact
that we will be using
a patient-level data
and location like
address information et cetera.
The higher level, of course,
one can think about
other health
priorities to address
before this one and so.
Some concrete next steps.
Some milestones
that we would like
to reach in the
next year, I guess.
We believe that we
can at least solve
the technical parts of
the project within
this coming year.
First of all, we would
investigate whether
these additional sources
of data that we
believe would be helpful are
actually available to us.
The second step
which we can start
after the first few months of
getting started with
the project would be actually
this machine learning step
of doing these predictions,
of predicting hotspots and
effectiveness of
spraying et cetera.
The last step would be actually
the optimizations step.
I forgot to mention,
this is actually
a relatively large scale problem
because there's actually
a thousand possible
villages where
we could be spraying
giving rise to
a huge number of possible routes
for the health workers,
so we would have to do some work
on scalability at least.
If successful, this AI
based prevention approach
would be deployed
by the government.
We don't think that
there is a need for a
particularly fancy like
application to share the route.
Instead, these can be
shared by just simply
text message or
a paper-based transmissions.
We have identified two strategies
for evaluating the impact
of our proposed approach.
First of all, we can
go back and track
now a decrease, hopefully,
in the new cases of VL
for that given year,
and then we can hopefully also
showcase that maybe we we're
able to increase the number of
houses that actually
were sprayed.
All right. This is it.
Thank you very much for
your time and attention.
>> [inaudible] have one question.
>> All right.
>> So I was wondering,
can you just train everyone to
spray their own house?
Is it very hard?
>> So, you would still
have I guess to get
to them the product.
So, even if they
knew how to spray,
they'd need to have the tools
and the chemicals
needed to spray.
So you'd have a similar kind
of routing problem, right?
You need to go and
to drop this off.
But maybe actually, now
that I think about it,
it's maybe a good idea
because you can
always go and do it earlier.
So now you don't have this
time constraint anymore.
So also you may have-
>> Make sure the drugs reach
everybody ahead of time.
>> Right. You're right.
>> Then you could train people.
I don't know, maybe.
You know better.
>> In the public health system,
you said they're not.
Make sure that [inaudible]
have enough stocks.
>> I see.
>> They're [inaudible] the stocks
that [inaudible] before we start it.
Okay, everyone is
spraying and it's not how
much your product [inaudible].
There's also another word
of mouth, right?
You just leave it
to the [inaudible]
As a public heath intervention,
they will have to
introduce [inaudible].
>> So that's actually
part of the [inaudible]
>> I guess a while this
stops the time constraint,
maybe you need more tools, right?
You need the equipment
as well to spray,
which would be more costly so,
and we do have limitations in
the amount of product
that's available as well.